foreign
the last time I brought up this subject
it resulted in a two-week news cycle
about translucent mermaids so we'll try
to beat that record this time around
Hallie Bailey who I have to keep being
reminded is a person completely distinct
from Halle Berry has been doing the
media rounds in preparation for the
release of the live-action Little
Mermaid which I think comes out soon uh
in which bayley plays the race swapped
version of the titular character
but there will be other adjustments and
edits made this time around uh we're
being told as up rocks reports quote
Halle Bailey has a monster year in store
her leading turn as Ariel and Disney's
Little Mermaid live remake is out in May
but her Ariel doll is already in demand
Bailey's also set to Star as Neddy in
The Color Purple in December and she
talked about the weight of both roles as
the cover star of Edition modern
luxuries
Edition Modern Luxury is that the that's
the whole Magazine anyway addition
modern luxuries March issue in the
accompanying cover story bayley
explained how 2023 is a Little Mermaid
Left Behind the original versions shades
of sexism quote I'm really excited for
my version of the film because we've
definitely changed that perspective of
just her wanting to leave the ocean for
a boy it's way bigger than that it's
about herself her purpose her Freedom
her life and what she wants she
continued as women we are amazing we are
independent we are modern we are
everything and above and I'm glad that
Disney is updating some of these themes
Bailey has transparently talked about
the horrifically racist backlash she's
been subjected to since her Casting in
2019 she did so again with addition
quote seeing the world's reaction to it
was definitely a shock but seeing all
the baby's reaction all the brown and
black young girls really tore me up
emotionally it's not only honestly been
such a crazy ride and I genuinely feel
shocked and honored and grateful to be
in this position a lot of times I have
to pinch myself and be like is this real
life
now
you should know that the um claim of
horrifically racist backlash is
supported with a link to an article from
the same website a few years ago also
claiming that there was racist backlash
but neither the original article nor
this new one ever specifically cite any
example of racist backlash this is a
trend that holds true for almost any
article or media report about racist
backlash against this film or racist
backlash against any other film
you'll you'll hear about the backlash
you can read stories about the backlash
the actors in the film will speak out
bravely against the backlash people will
denounce the backlash but nobody will
ever show you the backlash
you never actually see where this
backlash is happening
because it's mostly fictional the racist
backlash against The Black Mermaid is as
fictional as the mermaid herself in
truth very few people have actually
complained that the mermaid is black and
the few who have mentioned the race like
myself for example I've mentioned it
have made points that can't be
reasonably construed as racist by any
thinking person which is why they won't
provide any examples of what we're
actually saying so in my case just to
review
I am opposed in general to these Dei
race swaps of classic characters for two
reasons one
back to the theme of double standards if
it went the other way
every single one of these media Outlets
would be condemning it as racial
appropriation all of them and we all
know they would
okay I happen to believe in holding his
people to their own standard which means
that since they would complain about
black characters being made white we
should call them out for making white
characters black this is not our
standard but theirs if so-called
whitewashing is a problem then so is
black washing you don't get to make up
different rules or at least if you do
we're going to call you out on it that's
it
two there is an obvious Point behind the
race swaps it's not a matter of them
simply hiring the actor who happens to
have the best audition to return to an
example I've used before Morgan
Freeman's character in Shawshank
Redemption was written to be a white
Irish guy hence the name red
but nobody ever complained that they
made him black most don't even know that
the character was supposed to be white
because they didn't make him black for
the sake of him being black they made
him black because Morgan Freeman was
made for that role and it's impossible
to imagine anyone else playing it
that's the kind of race swapping that no
one has a problem with or should have a
problem with but it's different these
days because now they specifically look
for a non-white actor to take these
traditionally white roles this is an
actual targeted and intentional campaign
to minimize the number of White
characters on screen there's no question
that they're doing this they'll tell you
that they're doing it and given those
intentions I object
I think it's a bad thing to
intentionally erase white people you
know white people from films by erasing
White characters I don't think you
should do that and it gets worse the
more they do it the latest now is the
new Peter Pan film where both Peter Pan
and Tinkerbell have been made non-white
and then a few of the lost boys have
been made into girls as well again
none of this is happenstance as a result
of casting the best actors for the roles
if it was then who cares it was a
decision made ahead of time
to find someone who is not white to
portray these traditionally White
characters
now of course they celebrate the race
swabs they speak tearfully about what it
means for quote black and brown children
to be quote represented by yet another
white character turned black but if you
dare suggest
that white children will feel less
represented
you'll be mocked and screamed at and
accused of making a big deal out of the
thing that they themselves are insisting
is a big deal
I mean they're crying about how great it
is and then if you say you know I I'm
not sure that I really agree why are you
making such a big deal about this
that's the game here they erase the
White characters they applaud themselves
loudly for doing it but if you notice
what they're doing and you say even one
word about it
you're Petty and ridiculous and also of
course racist no matter what you say
indeed this very segment is guaranteed
to end up reported by left me left-wing
media Outlets with a headline like Matt
Walsh goes on crazed racist rant about
Little Mermaid
there's no way of discussing the very
open very clear very intentional agenda
of minimizing white representation on
screen without automatically being
accused of petty bigotry This Is How
They rig things the ultimate crime
according to the left is the crime of
noticing they do things they do these
things loudly and proudly but you cannot
notice that they are doing the things
to Simply notice it is to commit a grave
sin of some kind
but of course with these woke remakes
it's not just about adjusting the racial
makeup of the characters it's also about
updating the themes as Bailey says in
this case they're going to correct some
of the sexism quote unquote of the
original by ensuring that the mermaid
leaves the ocean not to chase some dude
but to pursue her own personal
fulfillment after all Bailey clarifies
women are all amazing and they're
independent and they're modern
and she's right about that last point at
least I mean all women living today are
modern in the sense that they are living
today
not much of an achievement though I mean
being born at this point in the
chronology of human events is not in
itself a virtue nor does it
automatically make you you right or does
it vindicate your your value systems
just because it happens to be the thing
that's happening right now
this is a fact that comes as news to
progressives as chronological snobbery
is a characteristic inherent to
progressivism I mean it's right there in
the name of the ideology
recently we've discussed the growing
scourge
in the publishing world called
sensitivity readers and these are the
woe call monitors who are paid to read
old books sometimes new books do and
make updates to the author's language
and themes so that they reflect leftist
values and often these updates are made
without the author's consent because
often the author is dead cannot consent
and this is essentially what Disney is
doing with its own catalog right now
um I wouldn't be very surprised if they
actually hired sensitivity viewers to
watch the old cartoons and make
suggestions about how best to bring them
into Conformity with current left-wing
sensibilities
but whatever the process they follow
this is what they're doing and just as a
sensitivity readers are hamstrung by
their inability to understand the text
that they're butchering
the same goes for the woke updators at
Disney
I mean it's bad enough that they're
cannibalizing their own intellectual
property worse they don't even
understand their own intellectual
property
I mean I last watched The Little Mermaid
uh all the way through like 30 years ago
I guess
and even I remember that in the original
version uh the The Little Mermaid was
already motivated to leave the ocean
before she met the guy she sang a whole
song about it didn't she
so the the girl power I want to break
free from my patriarchal father
politically correct motif
was already firmly in place in the
original
their brilliant idea for modernizing the
story then is just to do more of that
at the expense of further minimizing the
classical romance elements
this is how they add Nuance you know
when you always hear them talk about
Nuance oh we're making it more nuanced
well they add Nuance by removing Nuance
so that the characters are motivated
entirely by Boring self-actualization
mumbo jumbo mumbo jumbo rather than just
partially being motivated By Boring
self-actualization mumbo jumbo
in fact this is how the left updates
everything from movies to books even
buildings
right for anything at all that they're
updating it means remove the Romantic
elements remove the the fanciful
elements remove anything that's like
beautiful creative unique like take all
that out
and replace it with a bland or more
banal
uglier version of what it already was
this is what they're doing with our
entire culture
which is why this Disney stuff is
important because it is just one
manifestation of this larger
far-reaching campaign and that is why
the whole campaign not just the new
Little Mermaid
is today canceled that'll do it for this
portion of shows and move over to the
members block hope to see you there and
uh if you want to join us there you can
become a member and by using Code Walsh
at checkout for two months free on all
annual plans hope to see you there if
not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]